[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo subito un
po particolare regala praticamente
ragazzi all'incirca un annetto fa più o
meno comunque a marzo dell'anno scorso
praticamente ragazzi avevo fatto uno
speciale all'incirca un anno fa su happy
visse per i 15.000 iscritti nei quali
ragazzi ogni volta che morivo dovevo
mangiarmi un cucchiaio di nutella per i
20 ragazzi la vela avevate apprezzato
tantissimo un anno fa e quindi ragazzi a
distanza di un anno volevo riprovarci su
over golf su aver lamentato non riuscirò
mai a dirlo comunque sull'ormai
famosissimo gioco sui conigli che si
ammazzano ogni volta che morirò ragazzi
dovrò mangiarvi un cucchiaio di nutella
e teatro ragazzi anche una delle modelle
che mi avete inviato voi quindi sono
anche un po i cazzi nostri con che regga
gli attrezzi del mestiere sono un
cucchiaio la nutella e poi ragazzi il
tedesco alex che ha ben due funzioni
perché durante il video mi servirà
ovviamente se mi devo pulire perché mi
sbordoni nutella e poi alla fine del
video
domani iniziamo perfetto ragazzi ci
siamo allora vediamo di aprire questo
questo scrigno fantastico dio e la
nutella più liquida che è veramente
abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita
oddio perfetto ragazzi ci siamo allora
vediamoli riuscire a fare un qualcosa di
decente si gioca per da subito per la
nutella è questione di vita o di morte
io ve lo dico qui a un perfetto gioco
questo non ricordo che i comandi magari
se facciamo un po di pratica all'inizio
era meglio una donna ok son partito
malissimo non poco ma guardati si gioca
chieda di attuare chi ai gladiatori a
chi radiatore non mi chiedete come cazzo
il fatto non lo so perché in genere
perdo sempre ma non importa
la prima è andata a radio se riusciamo a
fare tanto 6 scarsi dite che tenti di
batteri perché non ci riesce come cazzo
quarta a farmi buttare ko così ma
[ __ ]
io veramente se ci si mette pure la gui
cazzo come non avete idea vada col primo
madonna di che ragazzi milanesi secondo
me viene il diabete col col primo
cucchiaio ma non importa la madonna
ok primo è andato il primo è andato che
perfetto fatto il primo è il primo era
abbastanza piacevole effettivamente
quindi ci siamo
aspettate gli arrivi alla firma e poi ne
riparliamo allora un combattimento serio
come siccome si deve vai così ma è così
bastardo di merda guasta suo gap
supplica farsi perfetto mai vai o no no
no non mi ha preso non mi apre
[ __ ] ma come cazzo qua allora
benini riuscire a fare un qualcosa di
decente lurido stronz
[Applauso]
si no nos i ragazzi mi sento come se
fossi in una vera arena come se ci
stiamo giocando la vita sul carattere
tutte ma va poi mica l'ho buttata tutti
giù ne manca uno ne manca uno anch'io
sono caduto come cazzo forte accade
fuori strada e non vai a vicky è partito
su ragazzi tenetevi il conto uno la
faccio
se la faccio l'occhio no no eh vabbè ma
che cazzo sei d'accordo ragazzi doppio
perché sono morto due volte per la mia
gioia
si vabbè dai no io ho già la nausea
ancora ciò solo a guardarlo mi vien da
un'auto non è possibile è privo andato
caso a tuttosport
[Applauso]
sapevo che non dovevo morire due volte
di fila alla prossima cucchiaiata lo
stop perché non ce la faccio due di fila
sono un suicidio perfetto ragazze ci
giochiamo lo stomaco uno stomaco una
volta madonna madonna manco matrix marco
mathieu al filmato vi fanno il culo così
cazzo si vabbè lega ma come cazzo faccia
a batterle 2 che sonda solo già uno è
difficile anche a ragazzi ci hanno già
la faccio già pio vi prego basta allora
se io non faccio più video da domani
sono cazzi miei perché l'ho deciso io di
farla sto puttanata perfetto grande
sgobbare mio amico al posto mio poi alla
fine vinco io
dai forza forza forse aspetta che diano
una mano
no per come non detto mou servi a un
cazzo non serve a nessuno nutellata la
mangi pure tu
perché alla fine me la sto mangiando
solo io ma chi cazzo sei jackie chan
madonna non so come caschi valido si
vabbè ho capito la spada ragazzi che c'è
un'idea solca miglia che i da che idea
della madonna ma ballavano schivato
madonna con lo stimato ma non hanno
scavato si no sì
anche in qualche nel tuo telo infine un
con il culo
scusate lo sfogo ma ci voleva dopo 4
cazzo di cucchiai di nutella parquet
meno innanzi ad hoc che poi se muoio
sono cazzi tuoi
ascoltami come nemici ter italy per the
ok non rompermi i [ __ ] che già sono
mezzo allora se la magistratura
[Applauso]
guardati il divieto mentre combatti
katrien fino tutta quanta porca bastardo
che non si no fermo fermo un attimo
unica soprattutto scuola sfruttate
ragazzi chi sta minkia degli morire
25.000 volte giusto allora devo farne
due ragazzi devo farmene 2 dove uscirci
u1 andato no non è andato perfetto
[ __ ] devi morire e devi morire
perché cazzo se mi chiedevo fascia lo
faccio lo faccio lo faccio
devo farcela su coming chiamerà apparato
nella pal come fa paral mistico alpi
come fa a parare misti colpi via michele
ritirata nella madonna alla volta riesco
a fare qualcosa di decente senza
ingozzarmi di quello di quella [ __ ]
di quella un ragazzo sono sono a più di
metà rutelli questa era piena era piena
ma perché non avvertite quando ma un
fischio un gong luca meno tutto ma mica
non ti faccio neanche alzare so te ne
prendi anche se sei morto avete potete
che se mi fate ancora mangiare un
cucchiaio di nutella quest'opera infilo
nel culo tutto armi che mi stanno
inseguendo perché sono sempre in due
contro uno è morto ma non è morto né
morto né mostro adesso sei morto
no perché se ti rialzi che nei vecchi
ancora più vero che ha intonato ragazzi
solo sassi gruppo sarebbe un genocidio
però non lo uso perché troppo facile poi
dovevamo troppo sudare
[ __ ] baffa miyake disastro capolei
con lupo non va l'ho capito lo so lo so
che mi state guardando male fra causato
il lupo non lo uso più vado li guardano
di stop al tempo mi chiama sono un
[ __ ] come ho fatto a non schivarlo
rara nenti pure alzati alzati e cammina
alzati e cammina e allora sei un
deficiente si va più sono posso
ritirarmi
[Applauso]
di morire e [ __ ] non è possibile
guardare ma guarda se sì sì soli nu soul
io sono vivo io sono morto non solo
gravi come casa faccia essere vivo
ancora più amica dispetto al malleolo
lui lui con nonchalance mi pare i colpi
trudi socks a su camicia se ti rialzi
incassati ghiacci tenendo al 3 min
cassetti tenendo altresì
sì sì minchia che troppo comito ragazzi
sto andando nel panico abbiate pazienza
non c'è un po più lontana dalla toccata
non faccio andare a toccarmi non tardare
guardate il pezzo di me non conta se mi
tocchi ti denuncio io posso e tu no tu
lo devi morire morire è morto è morto e
che esso risulta 4 quello ragazzi alla
rispettare un attimo che ho visto
balzani 1 davanti a caso senza motivo
perché cazzo sei atterrato di schiena
cat arriva una cucchiaiata di nutella
nell'orecchio t'arriva na vi rendete
conto che sta roba era piena una volta
io non ce la fa rega non ce la faccio
più sto malissimo gioco più vasta basta
un gioco più sono perché c'ho le mani
sporche di nutella poi che approda se
potesse essere io l'enigmista come
tortura mettere di mangiare l'utility
[Applauso]
ma fango lo sa merde rapier si vede il
fondo alla prossima e l'utile l'ultima
cucchiaiata io dopo non c'è più niente
finito cioè quasi il fondo praticamente
cerco di rimandarla per far mettere
nello stomaco di digerire quella
mangiata prima perchè giuro non abbiano
reggeva neanche quella di prima di
cucchiaiata figuriamoci se ne legga un
altra c è impossibile sì sì sì sì minuti
diversi lo si legga sono sporco ovunque
sono sporchi ma se magari non mi guardo
le mani e gioco madonna devi morire e
devi morire se l'assenza di un altro
colpo subito io sono io
minchia di spero che ti sei fatto ma le
mani quel male che mi chiato ricordi per
tutta la vita per caso codice tesi si
sei bello fischia ft se per madonna ma
la primi prossimo telo vecchi nelle
palle più tofu guardalinee guardali
fabrio ne mancava uno cazzo ne mancava o
non è possibile regalare l'ultimo il più
grosso
si vabbè ma questo neanche un mammut
riesce a mangiarlo praticamente fini ci
sono i bordi ma a parte i bordi ho
finito il baratto tutto forse l'ho preso
troppo che non denunciata una persona a
mangiare il suo cucchiaio sta accadendo
cazzo di barattolo mi sono mangiato un
cazzo di barattolo di nutella cioè le
lacrime agli occhi se i prossimi giorni
non mi vedete pubblicare video perché
sono successo molto probabilmente ok
ragazzi che se la prossima volta mi
sveglio con un'altra idea brillante del
genere piuttosto non faccio un cazzo
perché che al suo nido che sto morendo
non riuscirò ad alzarmi l'asta segna ma
non ve lo faccio vedere per pietà è un
barattolo di nutella intero vale un mi
piace non lo so fate voi ragazzi io non
so che dirvi lasciamo perdere che
chiudiamo che questo questo supplizio
assurdo ragazzi seri non è piaciuto come
al solito stato il commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che
condivido tratta nella descrizione se
essere resi dischi freno ci rivediamo un
prossimo video si spera da ragazzi